Energy is very amazing! So amazing that we as a human species use about 15 TW in
No moment! This is equivalent to 15 trillion watts. Note that this light bulb is normal
Consume approximately 100 watts. One terawat can supply 10 billion
At the same time
Of the world's energy, the United States consumes about 25%, while Google alone consumes almost
0.013% This is enough energy to run 20,000 homes continuously
Food also contains energy, which is measured by calories or joules. One calorie of food is equal
Approximately 4,200 joules of energy. So how long will it take you to the socket
To get what is equivalent to a day of dietary energy? For example, the normal diet of a man
2500 calories, we will find that our bodies need about 10,000,000 joules of energy per day
Let's take something like your laptop, which charges about 50 joules per second
It will take the equivalent of 55 hours to ship yourself. On the other hand, if shipped from a power outlet
A microwave with an estimated 1500 joules per second, will take 1.9 hours!
The most amazing is the fact that this amount of energy costs 33 cents
In North America. 33 cents a day to charge power. Unfortunately, we can not
Connect ourselves to the electrical socket
But if you take all that energy, how big is the possible explosion? Well, one calorie
May equal 1 gram of explosive TNT. So if you ate 2500 calories
in a day. You'll see the equivalent of 44 grenades from World War II bombs.
A huge explosion!
But it's no secret that energy can do harm, in the end we've all tried it
Electric shock. But how much electrical shock is needed to kill a human being?
Surprisingly, it is few
7 ml amp, for at least 3 seconds
I would be accurate. This is equivalent to AAA batteries directly to the heart. As you see electricity
Kill by stopping the movement of the heart.
But our bodies built protection like your skin
So do not go to the heart directly. However, shocks such as lightning, balance fluctuations
In fact, the lightning bolt could hit 1 billion volts! And the reason that some people escape from lightning
Depends on the path taken in their bodies. If not reach the heart
He may come out alive
Which proves to you the power and splendor of nature. What surprises you more
That every minute, sufficient amount of sunlight to the surface of the earth is sufficient to need
The world of energy for a whole year, that's right, almost 174 beta-watts of power up
Earth from the sun! Of course, the biggest challenge is finding effective ways
To harness solar energy appropriately
All this energy and heat is an effective factor in the formation of wind; sometimes
Be too strong to be hurricanes. But not only wind turbines can benefit
Of the wind power to produce energy, scientists have proved that it is in sufficient quantities
It can prevent hurricanes. In a simplified way wind turbines remove some wind energy
To produce energy. The simulation showed theoretically that
If enough wind turbines are put together in danger zones
Will significantly reduce wind disasters
But regardless, is aerobic energy worth all this trouble? Click here and scan the AsapTHOUGHT sections
As we explore how air turbines really work, how much energy can they produce?
And the new technology that will change our future, I mean, can the world
That depends on wind energy?
We went to the GE Global Research Center in Germany, the leader in aerospace energy to explore.
There is a link in the description box below.
Subscribe to more weekly videos!